we're in the village of Gandhi in the
far north of Nigeria it's not far from
the Sahara and the desert is advancing
southwards at an estimated 600 meters
per year it's already started
encroaching on Gandhi and surroundings
this village is home to de hero the
farmer has spent his entire life here he
tells us he is worried about the growing
threat from the desert in the north and
his Arnold harvest is dwindling year
after year that's yeah I think taking
just a politically
let's see 400 max how many do you think
you get this year approximately 3 ellos
Gasquet of 25% over last year's
the encroachment is more than this and I
just sat in it you can be able to go
there one time we would my transit will
show you how decision is in Cochin and
when at least it is more than tricular
which is annually the farmer hires
herzman to graze their cattle on his
land so he can collect the manure
fertilizer and he's doing more to wood
of the deserts and plantain comes just
to reduce the limit all these neem trees
I planted where Nigeria has been
fighting their certification for decades
the government has a special budget for
forestry programs and has planted 200
kilometers of tree barriers in recent
years every year we ensure that
plantation takes place throughout the
year we don't just plant trees during
the rainy season it means you really dry
season we get trees the cluster of trees
are planted at designated locations to
hold back the desert winds that carry
the sand but residents of many rural
communities continue to cut down trees
to use the word for charcoal burning
desert off' occasion displaces
communities and threatens people's
livelihoods it's estimated that Nigeria
loses more than 5 billion dollars a year
as a result more sustainable solutions
are needed to successfully hold back the
advancing desert and the destruction it
causes